be sure to subscribe to langfocus and
click the notification button
man why does everyone say kanji are so
difficult this one looks pretty easy
so does this one and this one it's not
bad and how about the next one
oh my gosh what the heck is that
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today we're going to talk about the
japanese writing system
well not the entire writing system
japanese is written with three different
scripts hiragana
katakana and kanji which is the one that
we want to focus on today
hiragana and katakana were developed in
japan but kanji
are actually chinese characters that
were adapted to fit the japanese
language
kanji are logograms a logogram is a
character that represents a word
or a meaningful part of a word kanji are
not
characters that you read phonetically
but rather each kanji represents a
distinct idea
rather than a sound for example this
kanji on its own
represents the concept of a mountain but
just from looking at it there's no way
to know that it's pronounced as yama
you have to remember how the character
is pronounced and when you see the
character you associate it with the
sound
but some kanji do also contain a
phonetic element which is something
we'll look at later
japan initially came into contact with
chinese characters during diplomatic
missions between the han dynasty
and the yamato state of japan which
eventually led to the japanese adoption
and adaptation of kanji
i talked more about this in my video on
the japanese language which you can find
right here
if we include every kanji that has ever
been used in japanese there are tens of
thousands of them but of course that
includes many
obscure or archaic kanji that really
aren't worth learning for the average
person
in 1946 the japanese government aimed to
simplify orthography by limiting the
number of kanji to a smaller list of
1850 kanji known as the toyo kanji
or common use kanji that list has since
been updated to include 2136 basic kanji
which
are referred to as the joyou kanji or
regular use kanji
this list determines what kanji students
are expected to learn at school
and what kanji are used in official
government documents with this part of
the reform the japanese government also
simplified some of the more complex
kanji so that they could be read more
easily
these kanji are called shinjitai which
literally means new character forms
for example this kanji meaning iron the
component on the right was simplified
and this kanji meaning wide its inner
component was simplified like this
you might be aware that such a
simplification also occurred in the
adoption of simplified chinese writing
in china
but shinjitai were much more limited in
scope and these changes only affected a
limited number of characters in japanese
types of kanji kanji can be divided into
several categories of moji
or characters based on how each
character is formed
for example there are shoke moji this
refers to pictograph kanji such as this
one for mountain or this one for tree
these ones look something like the
objects that they represent
shijimoji and kaimoji are ideographs
characters that represent ideas rather
than visually representing an object
for example this kanji meaning up and
this one meaning
rest the difference between these two
types of ideographs
is that shijimoji are rather simple
whereas kaimoji
are compound idiographs that use
multiple components that combine
together to create an overall meaning
with each of the components also
existing as
independent kanji the component on the
left means person
and the component on the right means
tree a person leaning against the tree
is
resting this is a good example of a kai
emoji
another example is this kanji let's see
if we can figure out what this one means
by looking at the components
i see this character which i know means
mountain and i see this one which means
up
and this one which means down so i'm
going to guess that this kanji has
something to do with
traveling up or down a mountain like
maybe it's hiking
now if we look at the actual meaning of
this kanji we'll see that it means a
path through the mountains
or a mountain pass so i'd say that's
pretty close
this type of kanji that kind of tells a
story is a kai emoji but only a small
number of kanji tell a comprehensible
story like that
by far the largest grouping of kanji is
kesemoji
these are kanji that combine semantic
and phonetic elements to make up a new
character
the phonetic element is derived from the
chinese pronunciation of the kanji the
onyomi
which we'll talk about later a good
example of kesemoji
is shi which means poem if we look at
the left side of the kanji we see this
component
which is most often used in characters
that have something to do with language
or speaking
such as this one meaning language and
this one meaning speaking
if we look at the component on the right
side of this kanji
we see the kanji for temple this doesn't
indicate any semantic connection to
temples
but rather it serves as an indicator of
how to pronounce this kanji the chinese
pronunciation of this kanji for temple
is shi or ji and when you see it as a
component within another kanji it
indicates that that kanji is pronounced
as she
or g radicals in the characters we
looked at in the previous example of
kesemoji
the component on the left is the radical
a radical is the main component of a
kanji that generally provides a clue
about its root meaning
some people use the term radical to
refer to any component of a kanji like
both of these
but to be precise only this element is
the radical
though both can be referred to as
components
every kanji contains one radical some
radicals also exist as
independent kanji such as this one
meaning gold or money
it appears as a radical with the root
meaning of metal here we can see it in
this kanji meaning iron
and in this one meaning copper other
radicals only exist as an inseparable
component of a kanji like
this one which shows that the kanji has
a meaning related to movement
like in this kanji meaning road and this
one meaning pass or communicate
as for phonetic components they don't
appear in all kanji but they appear on
many of them
and can be very useful in pronouncing
kanji one example is this one which we
saw before in the kanji for copper
this kanji on its own is pronounced do
and when you see it as a component in
another kanji it indicates that the
pronunciation is do
or to as you can see these kanji here
have nothing to do with each other
semantically and the radicals are
different they're only related in
pronunciation
another quick example is this kanji
meaning opposition
it's pronounced han now look at this
kanji meaning cooked rice or meal
it's also pronounced han based on that
phonetic element
and so is this one meaning sales and
this one meaning printing or publishing
they're all pronounced han well they're
sometimes pronounced han
sometimes what do you mean sometimes the
phonetic elements of kanji are based on
the chinese reading of the kanji also
known as the onyomi reading
and yomi just means reading by the way
onnyomi and kunyomi if you remember from
my previous video on japanese there are
two basic ways to pronounce kanji
onnyomi chinese derived readings and
kunyomi
native japanese readings for example
this character has a native kun reading
of
kata while also having the own reading
hen
when used in this word meaning a broken
piece
the onyomi is used when used in this
word katamici
meaning each way the native kunyomi is
used
the real complexity comes with the kanji
that have multiple
own readings and multiple [ __ ] readings
requiring you to choose the correct
reading based on the context
one example is this kanji meaning life
or birth
it has two onyomi readings say and show
so we have this word jinsei meaning
human life
and this word chiksho which means beast
or
dammit and it also has numerous kunyomi
readings here are some examples
there's ikiru meaning to live there's
umu meaning to give birth there's
meaning to grow there's hayaru meaning
to grow or spring up
there's ki meaning pure or raw and
there's nama
meaning raw or uncooked as you can see
it's not always a simple matter of one
kanji being equivalent to one word the
kanji is used to represent the core
meaning of the word but when we use them
for native japanese verbs and adjectives
a string of hiragana is attached to the
end to represent the inflection of the
word
for example let's look at the adjective
for cold samui
as you can see there's a kanji and the
additional hiragana
e the kanji carries the core meaning of
the word while the inflection
shown in hiragana shows us that this
word is in the non-past positive form
for an e-type adjective
so we read this as samui but when we
inflect this word in the negative
it becomes where kunai replaces e to
indicate the non-past
negative form when we look at this word
we know to read it as
samukunai with the first two syllables
represented by the kanji
and the others placed after it to show
inflection kanji also worked this way
with
verbs where the kanji will represent the
core meaning of the verb
and the hiragana represent the verb's
conjugation
why bother using kanji if part of the
writing is in hiragana anyway
even though kanji take a lot of effort
to learn they actually make the entire
language
easier to read let's take a look at an
example sentence first written without
kanji and next written with kanji
the sentence means i eat japanese food
because japanese is written without
spaces without the kanji the words all
blend together
and it's sometimes difficult to quickly
see where one word ends and where the
next word begins or it's difficult to
see what part of speech or word is
kanji are not really read but just
recognized like symbols so they allow
you to quickly skim a sentence for
meaning
but while kanji make japanese easier to
read once you know them
they make japanese much harder to write
by hand as you can see
some kanji consist of lots of different
lines or strokes
for example this kanji meaning machine
or opportunity
has 16 strokes
this one meaning a praise has 23 strokes
if we dig back into some historical
kanji that are not part of the current
joyou kanji
some of them have quite a high number of
strokes this kanji meaning rough or
crude has
33 strokes you can see that this one is
actually created through reduplication
of the same component three times
that component is the kanji meaning deer
here's another kanji meaning dragons on
the move which has
48 strokes and consists of the kanji for
dragon reduplicated 3 times as
components and this kanji features the
same component 4 times for a total of 64
strokes
it means verbose the biggest freak show
of a kanji
is this one with 84 strokes it features
this kanji as a component
which is itself a reduplication of the
kanji for cloud
and it also features the dragons on the
move kanji as a component
i don't think the origins or usage of
this kanji are very clear
but it may have been used in personal
names these high stroke kanji are very
rare and they're not really used anymore
but kanji of up to 20 strokes or even a
little higher are quite common
not only do you have to remember the
strokes themselves but you have to write
them in the correct order in the correct
direction
there are a series of rules that govern
stroke order the most basic rule is
top to bottom and left to right with the
kanji for river we can see that you
write a stroke from top to bottom
then you move to the right and add two
more strokes but the first stroke seems
to go from right to left
that's true but here the top to bottom
rule takes precedence so this is allowed
next when vertical and horizontal
strokes cross
the horizontal line is usually written
first we can see this in the kanji for
10.
next vertical strokes that cross through
other strokes
are written after the strokes they cross
through we can see this in the kanji
meaning middle or
in horizontal strokes that cross through
other strokes are written last
we can see this in the kanji for mother
next
diagonal strokes are written right to
left before left to right
as we can see in the kanji meaning
letter or writings next
central vertical strokes are written
before their wings
we can see this in the kanji meaning
water
next left vertical strokes are written
before strokes that go across
and down as we can see in the kanji
meaning mouth
this across and down stroke is quite
common and it's important not to mistake
it for two strokes it's just one stroke
next enclosures are normally written
before the components inside them
we can see that in the kanji meaning
wide
[Music]
an exception to that is some enclosures
that have a bottom stroke which are
written last
we can see this in the kanji meaning
near
and short little strokes or dashes are
often written last
even if that contradicts the top to
bottom rule we can see this in the kanji
meaning
seek most of these stroke order rules
become
second nature after a while if you
practice but i must admit that i hardly
ever write kanji by hand these days
these days people type on their
smartphones and computers a lot more
than they write by hand
when typing kanji on a smartphone or
computer you type the phonetic
pronunciation
and then a list of kanji with that
pronunciation appears and you choose
the appropriate one a well-known result
of this reliance on technology is that
japanese speakers ability to write kanji
by hand has declined
it's pretty common to see someone
filling out a form or something and then
pull out a smartphone to check how to
write a certain kanji
it's important to point out that not
every native speaker of japanese will be
able to read every kanji character that
they encounter
especially in place names or personal
names it's not uncommon for me to ask a
native speaker how to pronounce the name
of a place for example
and for them to tell me that they don't
know but they can often give it a shot
based on what looks like a phonetic
element in the kanji
and if they don't know the meaning they
might be able to guess the general
meaning based on the radical of the
kanji
while learning kanji is time consuming
and may seem overwhelming
remember that kanji are a part of
japanese culture history and literature
and if you treat them like a puzzle to
solve or a mystery to unravel
then it becomes much more motivating and
the kanji seem much less
intimidating the question of the day for
native speakers of japanese
do you think kanji are necessary for the
japanese language
would you be able to speak japanese the
same as you do now if kanji were not a
part of the language
and for learners of japanese how much of
a challenge are kanji for you
and how do you deal with the challenge
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and
instagram and once again thank you to
all of my amazing patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen
who are my top tier patreon supporters
thank you for watching and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you